I guess tonight has won eight Emmy
Awards that's too many that's at least
six two minutes I mean it's a lot you
deserve them you deserve them I just
think no person should have that many
Emmys that's me personally but for her
outstanding and hilarious performances
on Seinfeld the new adventures of old
Christine and of course veep I'm
thrilled to have her join me here
tonight please welcome our good friend
Julia louis-dreyfus
how are you well I've never been better
isn't this just fantastic yeah it's a
dream how are you coping how are you
coping day in and day out with people
what are you doing
well I'm cooking and all I can tell you
it's really good that this zoom
interview is from here up because from
here down
we got trouble my friend so you're
saying you've you've gained a little
weight maybe I I think I've gained some
weight based on the jeans and I'm
wearing and the difficulty I had closing
them today I have had the top button and
now top two buttons of my jeans erotic
zoom talk by the way
come on to you I'm saying I just like
eat batter out of a bowl you know my son
will be making and you know I almost
have a oh well it's a pandemic so all
the rules are off which isn't true I
shouldn't be thinking that way but I
think we're all doing that I know I
think we are are too and my hope is that
when we all come out of this everybody
will just be 10 pounds heavier and
that'll just be the norm no one will
know because we're all gonna be that
much heavier yeah the scale will just
sort of all go we'll all go up like that
Taylor and for no one will be saying but
noticing how hideous we work that's my
that's my that's my hope in terms of
endemic we can always dream we can
always dream that we'll all be equally
fat together now I'm looking at you
right now and I have a question
yeah it's about your hair um I'm
I'm noticing it's long yeah it's getting
long in front
yeah I'm fine that is a guy all you have
to do is take one of those buzz razors
you know and you can kind of neat it up
a little on the side and then let me see
the other side what yeah I see you
buzzed it there uh-huh buzz it there a
little bit and also then what happens is
I often do that when I get out of the
shower you do a little there and then
you look down at the chest and you go
might as well and you start working on
the chest a little bit here anymore it's
fine this is gonna get long and then
it's gonna it's gonna come forward like
some kind of a medieval beast it's gonna
come forward like that and the following
Conan let me tell you what you could do
it's gotten so long now you could do
well there are two things you could do
one is you could do it like a samurai
get a hair thingy dingy yes and do a
samurai that would look kind of neat I
think okay or you could get a barrette
and you could pouf it and barrette it
and you would have Elaine here from
Seinfeld
[Music]
look like Elaine Benes on Seinfeld
that's my dream speaking of beauty tips
yes something really funny you've done
this stay-at-home PSA oh yeah you love
it where you advise people to stay home
and I just want to put up this picture
of you after you've done your own makeup
what's but that it is really fantastic
how's that look going over for you um
well my phone stopped ringing if that's
your question do you think you will work
again that's my question
done done between that look and the like
35 extra pounds I've gained it's
finished wait you you got you've got a
pretty nice shout out online about your
new look yes I did did you see who
shouted out at me
did Chris say it Captain America baby
all right you wanted me to say it cuz
you didn't want to brag and then you
said Captain America baby yeah he is
he's one of the best looking men in the
world and he's his new celebrity crush
yes
that was so nice and did you see what I
tweeted back to him because you see
really the point of the PSA was to tell
people to stay the hell home and stay
six feet apart if you have to go out and
and so I said Avengers Assemble six feet
apart six feet up yes that's great
that's great
assemble while social distancing correct
you know and it's funny because
everybody's saying practice social
distancing which I think that that verb
is is a misleading I don't think they
should practice it they should do it
you know cuz practice suggests a
looseness about this and there is no
looseness here right now you take this
distancing thing very seriously what
happens when you encounter someone who's
not taking it seriously well honestly I
it's happened to me now once where I
confronted someone from afar I have a
sort of a road rage about this and I
think it's justified if you don't mind
my saying that in my defense I was in
CVS I had to go I had to pick up some
prescriptions and this woman walks by me
this close like she's like 18 inches
from my body so already I'm in having a
complete [ __ ] fit and then I look at I'm
so alarmed and then I look at her no
mask no gloves and I said hey don't walk
close to people and you should be
wearing a mask and gloves I say to her
and she looked at me like this I mean
she was so uh i frightened her I didn't
mean to frighten her but I had to let
her know that this is no
I know and I'm not really somebody who
does something like that a lot but this
time I really had to and I'm gonna
continue to do it did she know it was
you
no because I had on a mask I had on
gloves I'm like 78 pounds heavier
so I'm unrecognizable furthermore I've
got this I've put shoe polish in my hair
right now but I've got like that much
gray grow out uh-huh
so I look like a witch is what I'm
saying it looked like a wish I had this
gray I had this massive ass I've got a
mask like here and you know I mean it
was all bad III I guess I must have
frightened her with my look maybe I'm
nothing to do with what I was saying and
so so now I do you say you look like a
witch you're acting kind of like a witch
you're you're shouting in people get
away exactly
actually I will tell you one thing that
I did recently just this past weekend
which I was I'm psyched about I did I
went on to instil I have you done that
Conan I don't think I've done that I've
done a ton of zoom and I've done some
Skype what's insta live well I'm not
sure but I went on it it's on Instagram
I love your you bring it up I ask you
what it is
long ties idea get Mark Zuckerberg on
here he can tell you but I will say that
you've pushed the thing and then you're
live on your on your Instagram feed and
and then you can have a conversation
with somebody anyway what we did was I'd
never done it before did an insta Life
conversation with Tony Hale to discuss
the pilot of veep because HBO is
streaming all of this material for free
right now including our show and so I
thought oh that'd be fun and a good way
to raise money for Direct Relief which
is this organization that's on the
providing support to the front the
workers on the front lines health care
workers and so we did it and we have
this goal to raise you know we're hoping
we might raise $10,000 and we
$25,000 yeah bold yeah I know I heard
about this you doubled what you were
trying to achieve fantastic you know
Direct Relief which is a really good
cause and I'm gonna put that down I'm
not gonna do it someone much smarter
than me is putting that information
right now on the bottom of us this is a
great cause it is a great cause yes
we've got this great GoFundMe page you
they can find it on my something in
there yeah you're pointing to my
computer your technical terminology is
awful but we're gonna get the word out
please tell me that's gin you betcha I
know you seem kind of loose you seem
super loose I like it I want to mention
something that's really cool
before the pandemic and I want to stress
this before the pandemic you did a photo
shoot for People magazine in honor of
Earth Day yes now it's come out and
you're on the cover congratulations
thank you very much
thank you very much yeah it's for a
really good cause it's for NRDC
is that right yes the National Resources
Defense Council I'm on the board of that
organization and its really really about
we're talking about the climate crisis
and how it affects everyone and how it's
a non partisan issue
and that's very much a part of this
article and and frankly you know there's
an there's an aspect of this pandemic
right now that really there's an overlap
here and the overlap is that science
should be determining determining policy
and and and that's true of the pandemic
and that's true of the climate crisis
that we're we're feeling right now so
it's just a heightened awareness about
that and keep that conversation going
and because I'm a I'm an
environmentalist and I think really
probably most people are if they gave it
some thought yeah I think it's fair to
say that if there's
I like to try and look for the silver
lining and if there's a silver lining in
this crisis maybe it's that people will
start to accept that science is
extremely useful and yeah science saves
lives and maybe investing more in
science listening to what it's telling
us probably not a bad idea and you need
this yes one thing I want to ask you
before I wrap this up is if I sent you a
picture of me would it go oh behind you
you know yeah I see you've got Obama
would if I sent you a list of my 8 by 10
my showbiz 8 by 10 and I framed it would
it be butwait would it be autographed to
me or no I can autograph it if you want
that tends to lessen the value but
though it does there's a space right
over your shoulder where big picture of
me would confuse everybody just a big
smiling picture of me can I tell you
something in retrospect what I'm so
wishing right now I'm so wishing I had
had that therefore this entire
conversation and we had made no mention
of it that would have been FedEx that to
you well this has been a delight I
really always loved talking to you
likewise Conan you're very cool I like I
look forward to seeing you at 400 pounds
I'm I will be there too
yeah that's gonna be great we can shop
together one of those really called big
install stores correct we'll go to a big
and tall store together that'll be nice
I am looking forward to the Hollywood
red carpets right after this thing is
over and all everyone looking very
healthy let's just say 3 yeah so face
out full faced I want to make sure that
I mentioned again the NRDC the NRDC the
Natural Resources Defense Council which
is a
incredibly important critical
organization nationally and
internationally when it comes to saving
the earth well god bless you I don't say
that lightly I say it's a very few
people but I bow to you I doubt you
Coenen god bless you too and I will get
you a very overly large picture of me
for the background for your future
interviews just to confuse people okay
you know what I kind of would love it if
you do that don't don't forget to do
that I know all right take care hey
thank you so much for doing this thank
you for having me it's always a pleasure
all right go eat some cake batter okay
I'll see you later bye